Kaneda collapses,
unable to absorb the attack!
You were amazing.
Suekichi Kaneda.
Your courage deserves praise.
Don't take me lightly, you prick.
Huh?
You are the unified champion
in boxing, right?
And this is your fighting style?
Why didn't you continue attacking?
Only one more attack was needed
to make you the winner for sure.
Were you going easy on me?
Because I'm the weak one?
I've been a fan of you
since long before this match.
I repeatedly watched your matches.
No gloves, no shoes, and no rules.
Free from all the limitations, you can do
far more than this if you fight seriously!
You have a lot of spirit.
But the result is now absolute.
I admire you, Suekichi Kaneda.
I'm happy to unexpectedly see
a true warrior like you.
But...
there is a great wall standing between us.
-I don't want to kill--
-So you're taking me lightly!
I know well that I have no talent.
But...
it's the only thing I can do!
This man...
No one should judge me.
What's wrong with the weak
aiming to be the strong?!
Kaneda...
OHMA TOKITA
YAMASHITA CORPORATION
You finally showed your true colors.
It took too long.
I see now.
Among the fighters in this tournament,
he's the only one
who took over this tournament
as the weak one.
He fights to break away
from being weak.